Welcome to the Introduction to Automotive Visualization class.
By the end of this class, you should be familiar with the core principles to create a production-ready
automotive project from start to finish.
It's important to note that this course will introduce and discuss many topics pertaining
to automotive visualization.
However, many of these topics are discussed in greater detail in other classes.
During this class, we'll cover how to create a new project using the Unreal Engine Automotive
template, how to assemble our scene for cinematic quality lighting, how to light our scene with
various lighting techniques and post-processing effects, and finally how to quickly add a
turntable animation to the scene for our final render.
So let's get started.